If you're looking for some screams to stream,
Netflix has quite a few good options stocked
in its library right about now.
In addition to some of the titles everyone
already knows about, like It Follows, The
Babadook, The Conjuring and Hush, here are
some thrillers horror fans with a Netflix
account won't want to miss.
Last Shift
Directed and co-written by Anthony DiBlasi,
this indie fright flick follows a rookie cop
who's chosen to man an abandoned police station
the night before it closes for good.
The place is a cold, winding labyrinth, filled
with the eerie hum of fluorescent light bulbs.
And from the moment our hero steps through
the door, weird things start happening in
the hallways.
There's a mysterious phone call from a frightened
girl, something is banging around in the back,
and the furniture seems just a little too
frisky.
Things keep getting weirder, especially when
the rookie learns the history of a Manson-style
family and their weird connection to this
empty building.
Soon, she's running from bloody spectres and
horrific visions.
The horror never stops until the final bloody
showdown, so by the end of Last Shift, you'll
be left mumbling incoherently right alongside
her.
The Nightmare
This 2015 documentary is about real-life terrors,
which makes it far scarier than any fictional
horror story.
The Nightmare examines the awful and upsetting
mystery of sleep paralysis, a condition that
leaves its victims trapped in a conscious
dream as they see all sorts of horrible creatures
around them.
The film features eight people who suffer
from the disorder, and they describe in detail
how they can hear the sounds of the underworld
each night, and how they're haunted by demonic
shadow-men.
If that weren't scary enough, their devilish
visions are also re-created on-camera, giving
us a glimpse into the nightmare world these
people experience.
Let's just say, you'll probably want to stock
up on caffeine to stave off your own slumber
after this movie's over.
I Am the Pretty Thing That Lives in the House
A love letter to Gothic fiction, I am the
Pretty Thing that Lives in the House is an
atmospheric horror movie that slowly crawls
past the camera like a Victorian dream.
A narrator tells us in the opening minutes
that she'll be dead within the year.
Her name is Lily, and she's a hospice nurse,
caring for an elderly novelist in an old house;
one full of empty spaces and strange noises
which gets even creepier when Lily glimpses
an eerily beautiful ghost.
While you won't see any carnage, darkness
still permeates the film, from its ominous
doorways and suspicious mold to a disturbing
little mystery novel about a truly terrible
incident.
Thanks to Ruth Wilson's sad and lonely performance
and a creeping sense of certain doom, this
is one spooky gem that'll leave you unnerved
and more than a little worried about what
might be standing right behind you.
Under the Shadow
There are plenty of evil spirits haunting
Under the Shadow, but this Iranian film knows
there are scarier things than demons, like
the horrors of war or losing your kid.
Set in Tehran during the Iran-Iraq War, the
film sheds light on citizens who sought shelter
underground.
That's the world our heroine finds herself
in, as she tries to protect her kid from bombs...
and kidnapping djinn.
These spirits are drawn to fear and anxiety,
looking for something to possess, but as a
rational woman who doesn't believe in myths
or fairy tales, she has a hard time believing
these creatures even exist…
Until she starts seeing floating cloaks and
creepy old men.
What result is some genuinely creepy moments
that'll stick with you.
The Transfiguration
Screen vampires tend to be either hideous
or completely seductive, but Milo from The
Transfiguration stands apart from the fanged
crowd.
This young orphan from New York's streets
lives an isolated life, running from bullies,
visiting a counselor to discuss violent thoughts,
and watching disturbing animal videos online.
But Milo is far more than your typical messed-up
kid.
As he might put it himself, he's a "realistic"
vampire.
This boy is obsessed with everything undead
and spends his spare time stabbing victims
and drinking their blood.
Despite his thirst for the red stuff, he's
not a supernatural being.
He's just a mentally disturbed monster.
Without a doubt, The Transfiguration is one
of the most disturbing vampire movies ever
made and features a scene so horrific you
might have to stop watching.
But despite the brutality, this flick is an
original take on a tired genre, so if you
can stomach some serious gore, it might just
transfigure your opinion on vampires forever.
The Ritual
Forests are freaky places, and yet few films
utilize the environmental fright factor as
well as The Ritual.
The film follows four British city slickers,
hiking their way through Sweden, when they
make the mistake of taking a shortcut.
Their detour leads them into an incredibly
dense forest, where elk are impaled on trees
and something big is moving in the woods.
They encounter a creepy cabin, and are plagued
with nightmares that are a little too vivid.
Meanwhile, the thing moving in the woods keeps
getting closer, just as our central hero's
guilt over the violent loss of a friend starts
to take over.
As the group encounters occult symbols and
pagan rituals, it becomes apparent this was
the wrong place for a vacation, and we're
just as terrified as the characters when they
stumble upon horror after horror.
When they finally come face to face with the
thing that haunts them, it's one of the coolest-looking
monster concepts in recent horror history.
A Dark Song
Far more than just your typical haunted house
movie, A Dark Song is a deep dive into the
occult, a world of angels, demons, and complex
rituals that have to be performed in just
the right way…or else.
If magic were real, it would look like this:
methodical, miserable, and absolutely mad.
The plot follows a grieving, determined woman
named Sophia who's prepared to spend months
locked inside a house with an angry, overbearing
magician.
In order to move on from her grief, she needs
to meet her guardian angel and ask it to grant
her just one wish.
But reaching out to the spirit world is a
lengthy process, and if she steps outside
the house even once during the six month-long
ritual, she'll jeopardize her soul.
The magic rituals are absolutely grueling,
and as tempers flare and time loses all meaning,
the two characters begin falling apart, until
something from the other side peeks through.
Needless to say, if you delve into black magic,
things are going to get dark, but if you're
in the mood for a suspenseful slow burn and
a horror movie where the occult feels authentic
and agonizing, then you should do your best
to summon A Dark Song on Netflix.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!